Feldspar mineral...From the Ytterby Quarry.
How many elements does it contain? Shall we
take it home?
So terbium, just like europium, is often used
in television screens and
various types of displays and where it comes
in is that it gives green and
yellow colours, which in contrast to the red
and blue which europium
gives you, gives you the full selection that
you need to give colour
images.
So Ytterby Gruva, Ytterby Mine, what a great
place, the snow is falling.
This is designated Ytterby Mine, a historical
landmark for the discovery
of four periodic elements: yttrium, terbium,
erbium, and ytterbium.
Terbium was eventually discovered or eventually
isolated by the chemist
Mosander in 1843. It was from an earth called
itrea which was originated
in this quarry where we are right now in Ytterby
in Sweden. Terbium is a
really unusual element. It’s a metal; moderate
abundance. It’s called a
rare earth element, which is really quite
ironic because it’s not as rare as
its name would suggest. The abundance is something
like 20 to 30 times
that of silver, so I don’t think it’s
really rare. It doesn’t really have much
biological activity but we do find terbium
within the bones in the human
body and in animals but also within the kidneys
so you do find small
concentrations but it doesn’t really have
a perceived biological activity.
Terbium is also used in certain magnetic devices
and when you include it
in certain alloys it forms magnetic devices
which increase or decrease in
size depending on the strength or type of
magnetic field which they are
placed into which has various technological
applications. So terbium
alloys are really quite interesting because
they have what’s called
magnetostrictive behaviour. So what that means
is that the size of the
crystal or the size of the structure of the
alloy itself gets either larger or
smaller when it’s exposed to a large or
strong magnetic field. So, there’s
much research going into these terbium alloys
for small motors or small
switches perhaps and also to use as strain
gauges and other types of
really quite elaborate instruments. So these
may well provide us a lot of
new research in the areas of nano-science
and nano-machines.
Also, because of its fluorescence nature it’s
often used as a marker in
biochemistry so if you want to stain cells
and determine whether certain
types are present then you can use it for
that too.
So in terms of day-to-day life, where do we
find terbium? Well we find it
in unusual devices like energy-saving light-bulbs
because it stimulates or
it increases the yield of light in the mercury
discharge that we use to run
fluorescent strips. So we found it around
us in shops and houses, in
factories, street-lighting, everywhere. But
what I think is a really quite
nice and important application of terbium
is the fact that it’s used to
make phosphorescent materials. So these are
materials which generate
light or allow us to develop pictures if we
irradiate them with something
like an x-ray. And, in fact, terbium is used
to make very, very high light
yielding phosphors for use in screens and
visualisation screens for x-
rays. So what this means is that if I go into
the hospital for diagnostic x-
ray I no longer have to be exposed to long
periods of x-rays because
the terbium screen allows the generation of
the pictures at much, much
lower dose of x-ray. So it’s really quite
a significant advance. It’s really
quite nice chemistry as well.